vancouver unfortunately i have to
reschedule there's a lot that goes on to
getting in and out of our countries and
until that's a little easier
i'm gonna have to postpone the vancouver
and the edmonton shows
um but
thursday march 3rd i will be at zany's
for one night only and friday march 4th
and saturday march 5th i'll be in
lexington get all your tickets at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media please guys subscribe to
the youtube channel you're watching and
i appreciate the support hit that
subscribe button right there and um
patreon
look this community continues to grow
and every week
there's some new story i mean
we've you've heard me say it a million
times the girl with two [ __ ] is back
now one [ __ ] she's got one posting now
we've talked to a guy who died we talked
to a guy who solved an 18 year old cold
case we talked to a guy who cleans up
people's suicides and [ __ ] like
it is the wildest [ __ ] out there it's
five dollars a month if you sign up for
a year you get over a month free and
you're getting the honeydew a day early
ad free at no additional cost all right
if you or someone you know has that
story that has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
hopefully we get to do an episode
together all right now night pass nation
tour i want to apologize to vancouver
and edmonton unfortunately we have to
reschedule those dates there's a lot of
restrictions getting in and out of
canada right now and uh until that gets
a little
you know lighter i'm gonna have to
postpone those shows but i will be
coming i shot a promo for vancouver in
january of 2020 and before i even
created night pants okay and i'm still
gonna use that damn promo whenever the
[ __ ] i get there okay so i'm coming
vancouver i promise all right march 3rd
i will be in nashville at zany's one
night only march 4th and 5th i'm in
lexington kentucky all right that's the
info you know what we do over here we
highlight the lowlights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers and uh today i'm very
excited to have this guest on first time
here on the honeydew very excited to
have this baltimore royalty ladies and
gentlemen stavros hakios
did i get it right yes you got it you
got it baby yes nice to be here man nice
to be here with the only other actual
baltimore comedian that i know of so
yeah we were trying to figure out i mean
i don't i'm sure there are i just don't
know yeah yeah yeah yeah there's some
there's some guy who is not who does not
have a career like hey what the [ __ ]
what about me he's like sorry yeah it's
be honest you're not
uh nice yeah no uh i've been wanting to
do this for a long time i know i'm super
happy to be here uh this [ __ ] rocks
thank you this i can't believe your
studio is incredible i love this for you
i know i wish i had some i thought about
that i didn't bring any baltimore merch
i didn't bring any any natty bow
memorabilia
good to have you here hon dude it's nice
to be here you know what's funny oh yeah
baby you're doing so good and the funny
thing is when i do that sometimes my
daughter goes this baby laughs so hard
i'll go that's nice hon and my daughter
goes dad is that a man or a woman i go
it could be either in baltimore
they're involved the elderly in
baltimore were the first non-binary
people they're like they just got it
they kind of melt into one block
how you doing honey
come over here give me my palm
[Laughter]
yeah they just don't become one blob
that recedes into like a [ __ ] up arm
chair and they spend their their
twilight years smoking smoking menthols
and i couldn't
yeah man i'm happy i'm [ __ ] pumped to
be here all right we have a lot to talk
about before we get into a plug
everything
yes thank you uh guys i am going to be
in san francisco the end of february
25th and 26th i'm
you just said you rescheduled vancouver
as far as i know i'm still going to be
in vancouver but maybe i should take a
look at those restrictions
so for right now i'm in vancouver the
third through the fifth uh then i'm in
st louis chicago
both uh saturday and uh friday and
saturday sold out march 11th and 12th
we're adding sunday i hope and maybe
even a monday buy those tickets chicago
then burlington vermont charlotte
nashville atlanta
toronto providence i'm all over the
place dc philly uh and then yeah stavy
baby on uh twitter stuffybaby2 on
instagram and tiktok
you know i'm bringing a special i'm
going to release a special i'm actually
editing my special i shot it in la in
december i'm i'm in the middle of the
edit right now that'll probably come out
in march or april trying to figure all
that [ __ ] out where are you going to
release it i will probably self release
it you know yeah i just want people to
see it i mean i don't that's my biggest
thing is like that's it especially i
don't know if you experienced this but
when people just know you as like from
your podcast most people don't even know
your comedy so
and i i think podcasting's [ __ ] i
mean i can't i hate doing it yeah this
is fun but it's like i think it's such a
like i don't i've never done a podcast
of my own and been like oh fun you know
what i mean like
i've always been like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] i have to do to keep earning a
living whereas like i love stand-up and
that's the reason i got into comedy and
i've been doing it since i was you know
19 so
this is the thing i'm really most proud
of so it's like i don't even it's like
stand-up is this parent that had these
kids and podcasts and that [ __ ] up one
yeah yeah but they're [ __ ] up with
that family yeah but the [ __ ] up one
that was over there doing his job yeah
yeah podcasting's the only one he's the
doctor yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah or or maybe podcasting it
feels like is the kid that had like a
settlement for eating lead paint chips
and so now we're all rich off of it but
everyone hates it
podcasting comes through puts [ __ ]
thousands of dollars in your bank
account but it's all deformed and [ __ ]
up and you have to tend to it all the
time
uh but
anyway yeah man so yeah all that stuff
and uh you know just find me on the
internet that kind of thing come see me
and when the when this when the special
comes out please come please go watch it
you know here's the other thing too that
that a lot of podcasters and stand-ups
can't do is a lot of them
can't do stand-up yeah yeah a lot of
people see your podcast and then they
come see you do stand up like damn i
don't know you could do an hour that's
my favorite thing is how it's like
it's like uh you know it hurts my
feelings on one end because it's like
people like whoa you were funny you know
it's like actually people come and
they're like i want to see the guy
exactly they're like funny that was good
they're like i just want to see the guy
from the podcast that i knew and it's
like all right well so that's my
favorite thing is when people are like
you know surprised um but yeah man i
like i said that's the thing i i think
i'm the best at in the world and then
it's like but most people don't know you
from that skill so i'm pumped to just
get it out there and well i love dudes
like you but you especially like i go
back to the crab feast okay and i
remember
first hearing about patreon yeah and
someone says you gotta check out this
show called come town yeah yeah yeah and
i was like how's it spell and they're
like [ __ ] town i was like i don't know
who the [ __ ] these guys are but good for
them yeah yeah because right away i was
like
if you're telling me i'm about to see
something successful yeah good for them
because
every manager every agent every person
you know in your life would be like you
can't call yourself a hometown everyone
told us not to do of course they yeah
yeah yeah of course they did it it's
against all logic and i was like here's
some guys that were like you know what
yeah two of these we don't care come
down and now it's it's wildly successful
it's the producers of podcasting where
it's like we've done everything wrong
and it keeps working and we keep
now right now we hate the show yeah
that's also one of my plugs please get
off the compound patreon so that i can
move on with my life so i can move back
to baltimore and open up a surf and turf
restaurant which is my real destiny i'm
coming to eat there yeah please do yeah
i'll bring it to everybody
but hey man it's you know it's also
funny to be involved with something like
that and it's like you know whatever
it's uh it's been fun and obviously it's
like you know uh taking my baltimore
family out of poverty you know so that's
you can't you can't complain podcasting
does that yeah yeah so yeah i bought a
beautiful piece of uh uh property in
greek town which has you know very very
easy to get a piece of property in greek
town yeah
uh but yeah i'm happy with it man and uh
i guess it just [ __ ] you know like
i'm on tour right now um the reason
we're doing this podcast here is because
i have a bunch of west coast dates and i
was just like i'm not going to the
[ __ ] east coast where'd you uh what
venue did you shoot your special the
lodge room okay in highland park great
venue uh i'm actually doing a
birthday show there that i'll probably
be by the time this comes out it'll be
over i'm doing it next week but i love
that place um and yeah really nice
really interesting like
it was it's it used to be a masonic
lodge so it's like these weird [ __ ] up
like
you know
like ritualistic vi it's beautiful all
the like natural wood these
cool paintings but it's like
it's a it's a lot it's a masonic lodge
that was built in the early 1900s in la
like you know some [ __ ] up [ __ ] was
going on around there
there's
you'll still find the bones of a starlet
that was trying to make it inside in the
silent movie era
[Laughter]
yeah absolutely the pr the the brian
singers of the 20s
we're definitely in the large room being
like would you like to be in this next
mickey mouse shorts
we need a whistling a boy to whistle in
the mickey mouse short you know and then
just those kids are all he puts on a
goat head mask and just [ __ ] all those
kids you know you know that was going on
it was hell yes but you know uh it was
you know i want to do something a
different and it just looks cool has a
different vibe i didn't want my special
to look like you know
uh every i thought i like that people
are doing their own specials now and you
can put your own little spin on them
[ __ ] yeah i love every you know you
don't need the sweeping crane and all
like that's hey that's cool great that's
great
budget exactly but that kind of [ __ ]
adds like eighty thousand dollars for
like one cool shot yeah it's like uh
well for the credits i'm like don't
throw some black on white up there okay
we're good yeah yeah yeah exactly all
right so let's talk about you man
you said you pulled your family out of
poverty let's go back to the beginning
yeah yeah yeah yeah sure are you did
your family you're greek obviously yes
did your family come here from greece
yeah we're late your grandparents your
parents my parents were so we're like
we're recent immigrants i was the first
person born here in my family okay uh
they came over in the 80s
um which is it is interesting to like
you know like we're so
fresh fresh like it's just like my dad's
family's still in greece my mom's
they both have small families but we're
still you know their best friends are
still all in greece so it's like this
weird thing of like
you know i don't feel
you feel like of two worlds like if your
family came here when like
jerry curls were around you know what i
mean it's like that's not that long ago
you know what i mean so there wasn't a
black and white photo yeah yeah exactly
they were color photos you know what i
mean i was i was a bunch of you know
ninja turtles you were born there i was
born here i was born in baltimore now
that the late 80s they were married in
in
greece and came here yeah my mom's my
mom's this will show you like the greek
man's like uh [ __ ] mindset where it's
like here's how my mom's family got here
where my grandfather was a he was a
machine
shop worker
and he was just like going you know this
is greece in like
uh the 60s and like work's not that
great there was like a fascist dictator
shit's all [ __ ] up in greece so he's
just traveling around looking for work
anywhere like their family moved a lot
uh she grew up in northern greece and
they moved around a lot
and my grandfather gets this like
this this guy tells me about this insane
job he's like it pays this much the work
is this he's like what the [ __ ] this is
like
four times the money i've ever made in
my life he's like yeah i'll start where
is it he's like oh maybe i have to go to
athens or something he's like oh it's in
america and he's like what he's like all
right great he doesn't go he doesn't ask
his wife he doesn't ask his kids hey
want to go to america he comes home he's
like i'm going to america
he's like yeah i'll be there i'll send
uh six months later i'll send you guys
some money to come over and that's just
how it happened so it's like you know my
mom just like you know she
uh she was pretty she was older at the
time she she uh
came she moved over here like right
after
like high school so for her it was
devastating because it's like you're
about to go to college your college age
all your friends you know exactly
exactly and so uh but they moved over
here my mom moves back because she's
like [ __ ] america i don't want and to
get since you know you know about
baltimore geography this will not be
helpful for 99 of the people listening
but they were in like parkville you know
so like you know it's just like they
weren't even like in the city to have
any kind of like action before she's
married to your dad before she knows my
dad so what
and
it's like what is it about baltimore
yeah that brings
the greek families to there like why i
don't know what is it there well i can
tell because they know people exactly i
can tell you
the other the other like thing that
always
crushes me is in this story is that they
gave him two options and the options
were
new york or baltimore and he knew one
guy in baltimore was like i'm going to
baltimore and it's like you [ __ ]
we could have like a house in astoria
right now i live in a story of queens i
live in the neighborhood that you we i
could you know i could be the shitty
greek landlord instead of paying my
money to one i could be in a [ __ ]
tank top hosing off my driveway you know
with one of my balls hanging out of my
shorts that could have been me but you
wanted to go to [ __ ] baltimore
um so
anyway so yeah sashima's back meets my
dad and they're like we're gonna go make
money for a year in america
just never come like they they had never
thought they were gonna stay in america
and they've just been here and my whole
life growing up my dad every year was
like we're moving to greece you know
that right so i was like a little
[ __ ] kid i'm like you know you're
hearing that everybody i'm seven and i'm
like crying hugging my friends at summer
break and i'm like guys this is i'm
gonna miss you guys
did i just show up yeah you're still
you're still in little league
and everyone's like pumped to see me
every year they're like yeah yeah
he's back
that's great so that was def that was a
hilarious like
oh my god you don't want to go no yeah
they'd probably do and my dad and oh my
dad well my dad has this like all
immigrants have this like
the you know
fantasy of what it's like if you go back
home and it's like there's a reason you
[ __ ] left and that's how [ __ ]
delusional my dad is even in the middle
of the greek financial crisis right when
it's like
everything's getting slashed no one my
age my entire everyone my age just don't
have jobs they're just like their lives
are just [ __ ] and the jobs they do
have pay nothing
my dad still like we would have figured
it out it's like we're not figuring out
in america
you failed here you failed in the land
of opportunity you're not gonna succeed
there where it's like you know in the
middle of the most devastating financial
crash ever but are you an only child i'm
the oldest of uh three i have two
younger brothers all same parents same
parents yeah okay so
you are born what you're how old 31 i'm
31 89. all right you're the oldest i'm
the oldest yeah yeah i'm a and my family
is like i'm a child of i'm not a child
of divorce i'm a child of should have
been divorced you know what i mean like
i'm a child of like that immigrant
mentality of like oh let's
let's stay together for the kids not
just cause yeah not even for the listen
it wasn't for the kids
only one of us came out unscathed and it
ain't me it's my brother my brother nick
is like the greatest guy you'll ever
meet he's like and my brother they're
both great guys but it's like
i got some mental illness george
definitely got you know my brother me
and george are both artists i mean
obviously comedy stuff but george is
like a visual artist and his stuff's
incredible um art by zuzia on instagram
folks go check him out but uh yeah we
didn't come out of it unscathed i'll
tell you that much but you know whatever
what are you gonna do
so what did your dad do while he was
here he's a carpenter carpenter uh yeah
and he was good we have work when he
came here or they were like we're gonna
find it there he
the thing about my dad is he's very
talented it's actually he's similar to a
lot of comics in that you know the
comics the best comics
oftentimes don't really succeed because
they don't give a [ __ ] about the
business you know and can't like fig my
dad had no business acumen whatsoever
but he's like an insane i mean really
talented woodworker like has had his
work featured in like you know
architectural digest like a lot of he's
done a lot of like really really cool
stuff and he's insanely talented but
one of the worst businessmen of all time
like just like you know these these
[ __ ] shitty greek diner owners always
like haggling him down he's like
fine it's like you know i remember being
like 10 and working with him and being
like
why the [ __ ] are you letting this
[ __ ] you know what i mean it's just
like with my dad just i don't know he
just he was just good at that and he
never wanted to
because of that we're always moving back
mentality he never actually like was
like all right let me settle down and
make up a 20-year plan right which if he
had done and even if he had just
gotten a [ __ ] job or found a company
where he could have just like made
someone you know made to order
it whatever i don't [ __ ] know he
should have figured i was you know i'm a
[ __ ] baby when this is happening but
whatever he even if he just made that
plan he would have been much more
successful but every year he's like all
right i'll [ __ ] keep renting out my
own space i'll keep running my own
business all this [ __ ] and it just never
he never really figured it out so you
know that's always constant stress when
you're and he also has that like
um that like comics or even that like
artists thing of like
constant uh
um like uh procrastination you know what
i mean where it's like that's why i love
stand-up because it's like
i should work harder on my act but at
the end of the day
the show is happening right like i can't
just like there's a deadline that is
it's just gonna happen right and i like
i love that because i can get two in my
head but with my dad he was like that
but it's like okay well you have to
build like a library you know what i
mean
you can't really leave that to the last
day you know it's not a [ __ ] paper
you can [ __ ] it's like and so i he
would literally just like spend like he
would just not he was just like not work
go to the [ __ ] greek coffee houses
hang out with his [ __ ] friends who
are all avoiding their families as well
and just like for seven days just not
sleep and just like
put together the most beautiful [ __ ]
you've ever seen but then he's like
completely drained in a bad mood [ __ ] it
you know whatever
or he'd [ __ ] [ __ ] up because he's doing
things last minute so so you know just
the classic just
just scatter brain [ __ ] immigrant
like craftsman [ __ ] but what about your
mom what did she do my mom uh worked for
uh she repaired oriental rugs she's
really good at that thing that was like
a real
come off the boat like
we'll pay you under the table you know
they found this like uh hilarious
egyptian dude who was just like who
would only hire greek women for some
reason so he just like thought their
craftsmanship was good uh and my grandma
got that job got my mom the job got her
friends the job yeah yeah so my grandma
worked there
in the in the 70s when they came over
and that was on like you know
33rd street on in east baltimore um and
it was called michael's rug gallery and
then my mom also did for years was a
waitress on top of that so she had like
two jobs my dad had his own business
that was [ __ ] always
barely afloat and so
you know we we spent a lot of time in
rec centers you know the classic like
you know shout out to maura crossman i'm
just gonna get every baltimore reference
here so if you're if you're if you're if
you're this is going to be huge for the
baltimore base of the honeydew because
this is we are going to do way more
geographical shout outs to baltimore
than we are hard punch lines this
episode
[Laughter]
more shout out to moore cross when i
went to john rura elementary school but
it was great it was like you know that's
also the most fun because you're just
like out there playing sports you know
you don't you know you're just like you
know it was a great it was a really fun
childhood and i will give my parents
credit i did not even know we were broke
like my mom
the you know mom i don't know how moms
[ __ ] do it where it's like she has
three you know three boys uh constantly
you all ravenous we're all eating like
[ __ ] animals um
and you know my dad is essentially a
fourth child he doesn't do she's like
it's that immigrant [ __ ] of like i my
mom does my laundry and cooks for me
then i get married and my wife does my
laundry here
there was never a gap he literally lived
in his mother's house until he got
married and then he lived with his wife
like there's yeah no gaps and still you
go to greek town you'll see these
[ __ ] 30 year old guys that you'll see
out of the in the shittiest little town
homes just a [ __ ] tricked-out
mercedes a porsche like whatever because
it's like these guys live with their mom
who does everything for them and so they
just like spend all their money on their
car you know what i mean so it's like
you'll still see that in my neighborhood
to this day
um but
uh yeah so it was just like
um
you didn't know you were poor yeah i
didn't know i didn't know i was poor i
had no idea until like fafsa when when
it's like when you go to college and you
have to uh federal student aid something
okay and they ask you all these like
financial questions and i'm like to tell
you how much like you know how many
eight how much how many loans you're
gonna get how many like just free money
you're gonna get for being poor
and
and so
and i'm and i'm like you know i've spent
my whole life doing paperwork for my
immigrant family right like i was the
oldest so it's always like i'm
translating [ __ ] i'm always writing i
was writing letters for my mom when i
was in fourth grade you know like that
kind of [ __ ] and so we're sitting down
at the computer and my mom's english is
a lot better than my dad's my dad's just
like you couldn't even have a
conversation with my father still he's
been in the country 40 years um and
procrastinating he's progressing
i'm going to learn it
he's speaking at us i would say seventh
grade level right now he's like he's
like it's like talking to a surly middle
schooler
yeah yeah yeah i'm not look you want to
talk about lumber you want to talk about
you know
cabinets
he can talk that that's the only [ __ ] he
can talk about
um so uh we're filling out fafsa and
it's like um and they ask you like
what's your net worth that's one of the
questions and my mom says zero and i'm
like no mom now i'm like i'm like she
doesn't [ __ ] [ __ ] immigrant
doesn't [ __ ] know it been in the
country doesn't know what net worth
means and i'm like no it means how much
money we totally have and she's like i
know
it's zero
like what we have no money like i didn't
think we had a lot but we have zero
money
how the [ __ ] am i even alive i was like
and it's like it's a testament to her
that i'm like i'm 18 and it never dawned
on me that we're my parents are just
massively in debt just making [ __ ] you
know so uh so yeah credit to immigrant
moms i don't know how the [ __ ] they do
it just like and we didn't even have
that big a family either but
she made it work man she she did
everything yeah two jobs talk about that
because
it's really important you say that
because here's
here are three kids who are clothed yeah
you got a roof over your head with some
heat yeah
you might be eating doritos and [ __ ]
yeah
we were we were [ __ ] up spam i'll
tell you that much
there's a lot of [ __ ] there's a lot of
[ __ ] and that's another thing it's like
i don't look i'm doing okay like we're
it's podcasting has kind of become like
this middle class
the one way you can become like a middle
class like artist basically where it's
like because before it was like
you're either like a [ __ ] millionaire
you're either like going on arena tours
you know what i mean you're like burr or
something like that or you're like you
know barely scraping by
maybe touring 40 weeks a year making
like 80 grand and you still have a
family it's [ __ ] brutal podcasting i
feel like for me anyway has like
afforded me like
a nice life right and i don't have kids
thank god so it's yet so yeah
thank god i could i couldn't deal with
them yet
but uh but it's like i think about that
sometimes where i'm like do i want my
kids growing up knowing what real ramen
is you know what i mean because it's
like because it's like everyone i knew
who knew what ramen was before the age
of it was like
they're pieces of [ __ ] you know what i
mean like they're just like
uh so yeah a lot of ramen i thought
ramen was sick i thought hot dogs were
like like hebrew nationals i was like
this is
[ __ ] prime rib not sk you know what i
mean nah nah see that's what i'm saying
yeah that's that's my mom like it was i
was good to think like i created these
class hierarchies because the other
thing is like you know [ __ ] baltimore
it's like you have all these [ __ ]
white trash kids running around who are
way everywhere who are way like like the
immigrant thing is nice because we got
lucky because
we didn't have like the baggage of
america american like culture that just
honestly has been failing poor people
since the new deal was the last time we
did anything good for poor people in
america and ever since then they've just
been you know [ __ ] them up so like we
had we were poor but it was like we had
an intact like you know like family unit
when like my mom would go above and
beyond and do [ __ ] she shouldn't have
had to do right like that's the thing
it's i'm not blaming the kids whose like
parents couldn't handle it because like
you shouldn't have to go to work go to
your first job take your kid to [ __ ]
soccer practice cook clean go to your
second job drop it my mom would drive me
to you know baltimore city schools are
[ __ ] dog [ __ ] there's all you have to
like get into like two good ones right
so you test into the school system and
if you're if your test scores are good
enough you get to go you have the
privilege of going to roland park is
where i went right
that's a half hour from my [ __ ] house
so my mom drives me there drives to work
like that's an hour her day takes me my
brothers couldn't get into that couldn't
get into that one
they weren't cutting the intellectual
mustard
uh and and so they had to go to it's
still a pretty good one southeast but
close to our house so she's just
bouncing my cousins yeah
that school's hilarious my brother his
first day of sixth grade right he's like
a nervous little you know you're still
like a fat little fifth grader who's
like scared you're like oh what's middle
school gonna be like first day he goes
to the bathroom a kid this kid who had
probably failed like four times in a row
he's like 16 years old an eighth grader
who's like got stubble he was driving
yeah he sees my brother he's like hey yo
let me get your pants
that's his first this first day in
middle school and my brother just
just [ __ ] sprints sprints back to
homeroom right so that's and by the way
that was the third best middle school in
baltimore city we're talking about it
right
it's funny because my um you'll love
this
so i want to talk about like i was
nowhere near poor but certainly did not
have and look we were living in a
classroom
yeah free lunch of course but
i'm sorry to [ __ ] just that's the
other thing about greek people and like
their weird pride is like
my mom wouldn't she was like you're not
getting free lunch and i was like we
quite like i was like oh mom these
people can't go on the forum these
people came in they said we
we qualify you know we probably qualify
we should check with our parents and
she's like no you're not doing it she
would like pay for lunch just like or
she would be like i'll pack your lunch
right because like she was she did it in
like a it's not healthy thing but it's
like she did it because she didn't want
the stigma of like
free in my opinion right but anyway
sorry to cut you off no no no i
because my mom had no problem getting
those
she had three kids she's like you're all
gone yeah yeah yeah i just remember
just feeling humiliated because you
would have to go the way it went in
school where we were you'd have to go in
the morning before school started and
get in this line with all the other
[ __ ] poor kids yeah in front of
everybody yeah everybody knew what you
were in there 100 because they had
breakfast too that was the other thing
some of the people in line had money to
buy an orange juice and a cookie or a
muffin or something to start their day
but i'm waiting in line to get my free
green [ __ ] like just raffle tickets
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then you have to
hold it all day you can't lose that
[ __ ] yeah yeah you got to be
responsible
saying that they made little kids
hold on to their tickets
and then you get in line with everyone
who's has money to pay for their lunch
and when you get to the register in
front of everybody you got to [ __ ]
use your voucher yeah
yeah yeah yeah i just remember being
like man this feels like totally and
then i would scrape enough money
together from like selling chocolates
for little league or whatever and by and
basically i'm eating them myself i'm
using my lawn mower
my cutting grass money and [ __ ] oh i
remember those boxes
and um
at the end of the week i would get my
friday pizza i would get my lunch ticket
but i'd bring like the buck 25 to get a
double pizza hell yeah dude then i felt
like i was like cheating the system like
here's this free ticket but also here
yeah i would just be every friday i
couldn't enjoy my [ __ ] right right
wow the guilt the guilt the guilt that
we put kids through and that's the other
thing is like why the [ __ ] are we why
doesn't every kid just get free [ __ ]
love for real it's a [ __ ] america
yeah like it's probably real it would
probably you 0.001 percent of the lotto
money and throw free lunches yeah it's
like it probably would save
administrative time just being like
we're not keeping track everyone gets it
like [ __ ] it all you can eat it's
ridiculous yeah although the uh yeah my
first
my mom would give us milk money right
because she was just like you should
have milk still it's funny how what a
hold the milk industry had over america
from like 1980 to like basically last
year
how much milk we were drinking i don't
drink any milk
i'm a oat milk guy now you know we've
all gone almond and all that kind of
[ __ ] but you know what's funny though
everybody i know that really drank milk
a lot growing up they're tall as [ __ ]
yeah it definitely has hormones that
sounds like baltimore science to me
brother it is true though hey look bro
you six three i drank milk
yeah he drank milk over there he's an
amazing milk drinker
he's drinking milk i want to tell you
this story because this is baltimore
mentality this is what happened you'll
know all these places so
my aunt marguerite
these are my cousins i talk about they
went to southeast they lived on macon
street
[Music]
right by right by where i grew up yeah
right where the train tracks are back
there in the little basketball courts
there so that was where i ran around
that tracy's right there across the
street okay so
she works at the rite aid on eastern
avenue all right she and a few ladies
worked there and um all of a sudden some
money starts missing so the higher ups
accuse the
uh register ladies of of stealing the
mm-hmm you know skimming yeah
yeah skimming off the top but it's
adding up to a lot of money and they're
like we're not [ __ ] doing this we're
not so my aunt marguerite gets a an
attorney
and i had to lawyer up
because they told her and those rest of
those ladies i think there were four
total my aunt and three other ladies
that if they don't take the slide
detector test and they're going to lose
their job so the attorney said listen
that's illegal so
let them if they tell you you have to
take this test or you're going to lose
your job take that test she goes are you
lying did you steal the money she's like
none of us took this money she's like
then you'll pass and then we're going to
sue the [ __ ] out of them
for making you take that test i love it
so they did
and they all passed and then there was
an internal investigation where they
found out that the execs were the ones
embezzling the money trying to blame it
on the ladies so wow why would those
[ __ ] make them take a [ __ ] lie
detector test crazy my aunt marguerite
gets 1.2 because she's wow she's the
ring leader and the other ladies
incredible here's baltimore mentality
308 south macon street they're like
we're getting the [ __ ] out of this yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
margarita she bought me a panasonic
12-speed
[Laughter]
yeah
enjoy those two extra gears
you're not poor anymore that 0.2 million
i got right there
oh my god what do they do they [ __ ]
get a house and they move where they
like finally they get the good school
system they can take them all they want
because they they also are raising their
grandkids my aunt marguerite's son i've
talked about before mental illness gets
a classic baltimore move so your
grandma's your mom yeah
yeah yeah yeah so they're they're with
their and they want to get their
grandkids out of southeastern good
school systems and and they throw two
middle finger fingers up and they go
right to rosedale hilarious there they
go
so if you don't know because you know
here's baltimore city yeah here's rose
it is the county it's literally it's two
exits up on 95. that's why that's where
i played soccer like it was in the same
oh
yeah it was still close enough so you
could see it you could see her whole
story
they get a house
get a little backyard probably pool they
go to what is it
i want someone to do a spreadsheet of
every just specific baltimore thing i
need to see the list when it's all said
and done i know so i know there's a
listener out there that's keeping track
today's program is brought to you by
athletic greens the health and wellness
company that makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really really simple with so
many stressors in life it's difficult to
maintain effective nutritional habits
and give our bodies the nutrients it
needs to thrive busy schedules poor
sleep exercise the environment work
stress or simply not eating enough of
the right foods can leave us deficient
in key nutritional areas i take ag-1
every morning i tell you about it all
the time drop it in a cup of water boom
head off for the day you're already
getting all the vitamins and nutrients
you need and one tasty scoop of ag-1
contains 75 vitamins minerals and whole
food-sourced ingredients including a
multi-vitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more in one
convenient daily serving the special
blend of high quality bioavailable
ingredients in a scoop of ag-1 work
together to fill the nutritional gaps in
your diet support energy and focus aid
with gut health and digestion and
support a healthy immune system
effectively replacing multiple products
or pills with one healthy delicious
drink join the movement of athletes moms
dads rookies first timers and everyone
in between taking ownership of their
daily health and focusing on the
nutritional products they really need in
the simplest manner possible to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you an immune supporting free one year
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs with your first purchase if you
visit athleticgreens.com
honeydew today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
honeydew to take control of your health
and give a g one a try mental health is
more prevalent now than ever you know
especially the last two years and this
show really i mean if you really think
about it is a mental wellness show so uh
new mood is here to guide you to mental
wellness and give you the tools you need
to tackle stress so you'll feel
empowered to take on whatever life
throws at you they have a team of
dedicated coaches so you have a support
system helping you and my favorite thing
about it is that's literally a
step-by-step guide to help manage your
mental wellness and you can do it at
your own pace you can arm yourself with
knowledge and the skills for happiness
and all you need is 10 minutes a day
it's an app so it's there for you
anytime anywhere all right taking care
of your mental wellness is empowering a
new mood is there to help you better
understand your personal relationship
with stress and anxious thoughts so you
can take control
worry less and feel happier sign up for
your trial at
noom.com honeydew that's n-o-o-m.com
honeydew start your trial today whether
it's saving more and spending less
getting organized or losing weight
there's a lot of worthwhile goals to set
for yourself this year and at the top of
my list is learning a new language with
babel the language learning app that
sold more than 10 million subscriptions
i'm taking spanish and i gotta tell you
migente me espanol es muy bueno all
right i was taking this before babel
came on board that's how much i believe
in babel and babel's 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lessons
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective and with babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and your accent there are
so many ways to learn with babel so in
addition to lessons you can access
podcasts games videos stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee start your new
language learning journey today with
babel right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com and use promo code
honeydew that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com code honeydew babble
language for life
now let's get back to the dude when it's
all said and done you know she was my
grandmom's sister and so we're all close
we're all extended family and and um
she's like ryan the kids are out of the
house now we did it i'm going to move
back because she kept the house on
making and just rented it out and she's
like i'm going to move back to to making
street i'm going to die in highland town
and that's exactly what she [ __ ] did
what a [ __ ] soul exactly
just eating crab chips nat drinking
shotgun
wearing that noodle running around
probably a nice short haircut
it was it was a nice short haircut it
was huge glasses big ass glasses and the
earrings
a lot of floral prints love it dude they
were all italian but so similar to that
yeah oh totally awesome oh that's so
like that's so [ __ ] sick so hilarious
that was it like we're out of here they
went right there i know well there is
that there's that total villager
mentality for everyone scared a little
bit scared to get too far that's all you
know man it really is i mean i grew up
that's what i find crazy about greek
town right because it's like
the the no one is fr very few people are
from like the same island or like it's
people from all over greece right whose
families came they carved out this
little [ __ ] you know niche of of uh
baltimore and like it's like yeah our
families moved here so we could do
whatever the [ __ ] we wanted
half the kid more than half the kids i
grew up with still there just live there
is that right it's like yeah married
each other like they left their families
left villages in greece and they just
created a village in southeast baltimore
and it's like they all intermarry like
all the kids i went to church with
they just it's almost like what's your
stuff it's almost like i got a show
called content yeah yeah yeah don't
subscribe
oh my god i've heard my i overheard my
mom talking to her friend on the phone
and she's like she's because my mom is
so proud of me too she's one of those
one of those moms that like
thought i was a genie like i thought i
was she was like she thought i was gonna
be one of those kids that goes like
harvard when he's 11. you know what i
mean like just thought just because i
was like uh i was i was good with
language really early on so i think
people really think like that means
you're a genius like no that's just my
only skill i'm [ __ ] stupid in almost
every other aspect of life but uh so
um she's talking to a friend and her
friend has like her friends kids are
insane right like these are some family
friends who are like they're all
chemical engineers they're all like you
know they actually like moved to greece
and then like left they were from new
york actually moved to greece and then
came back to south carolina weirdly
because they just wanted a nicer climate
but they didn't want to stay in greece
she's this woman's from queens
originally and she's like finally my
mom's like this is when things start
going good because you know i've been
doing i've been a stand-up since i was
19 13 years right and it's like i was
always a good student my mom used to
brag about me and then there was like a
six-year black hole of bragging where
i'm doing you know open mics and seafood
restaurants i'm [ __ ] you know did you
start in baltimore start in baltimore
yeah where i did uh
well my goobies were the first club i
worked but you know just overall you
know open mics in the in the there was a
an open market this place red roof
tavern
in uh canton there was uh high tops over
in timonium they did it they did stand
up there they used to do stand up it was
a [ __ ] dog [ __ ] show it's like one of
those shows hung out there when there's
13 comics
it was on wing night so i had a lot of
the high tops wings
and and it listen it's a sunday night
show
tvs are showing sunday night football
the people are playing [ __ ] pool in
the back it's one of those shows where
it's like 12 comics and then a headliner
you know what i mean where it's like and
when you first start you're like
well one day i'll i'll [ __ ] i'll be
the guy i'll headline
exactly
i'll make 125
and go 13th
i'm gonna be next door to stay fair i'll
come over when it's my turn dude but
that was like you know you don't know
any better you know and you're like
that's [ __ ] you know so there but
then also dc had a great scene so i
probably started i started when i was in
college and i did a few open mics around
and then i took i the immigrant guilt
hit me so like for a year and a half i
was super and i quit comedy again super
into school then i started going to
therapy because i was like i'm going
[ __ ] crazy what the [ __ ] i just was
racked by guilt and i literally had a
therapist who was like you should just
drop like drop out of college like you
know what you want to do and i didn't
because i was too scared but it was like
that was still like a guilt of what
immigrant girl i'm the first born son i
was on feel like you're letting your
family down exactly i'm in school for on
scholarship it's like
and look everyone who does comedy
you have you have some like
you have some like ego where you think
you can do it but also i wasn't [ __ ]
stupid i know odds part of me is like
this is a selfish pursuit and the odds
of me the odds absolutely dude
when people are like i just want to make
people laugh it's like well no you don't
you yeah you want to make people laugh
you also don't want a real job you want
to be the center of attention and you
want to get [ __ ] rich and be on tv
hopefully someday you're not doing it to
put a smile on someone's face you know
what i mean like uh we're doing it
because it's like selfish so you [ __ ]
give up relationships sure it'll it
absolutely sometimes absolutely go away
from people it's a very selfish endeavor
you know in so many you want to throw a
[Laughter]
sorry good thing we're we're friendly
that's uh that's another sign of
baltimore disrespect using too many
syllables where the man you just met
could end up in a could end up in a
switchblade fight
how's my stabbing acumen you piece of
[ __ ]
you think you're [ __ ] better than me
i knew i could say ackerman too
who just told me i was telling my stuff
so dare you man somebody told me this
story
oh was a guy on a patreon that came on
he was on a uh on the metro leaving uh
baltimore and he would happen to be
there the night the freddie gray riots
broke out and he's like oh my god i
lived him but i was just doing baltimore
when that happened where are you oh yeah
yeah i was [ __ ] [ __ ] up he said
he's on the train and he said this
[ __ ]
uh big black dude like
pulls a knife on another black dude on
the train and that black dude pulled his
out he's like what the [ __ ] going on
in baltimore they both got knives and
they're there like
oh yeah yeah you don't make eye contact
you're just [ __ ] you just [ __ ] go
about your business next stop yeah yeah
exactly exactly oh yeah
um no the yeah so the guilt you started
going to therapy why what i mean
i didn't i was so funny was that his
choice you made or was someone else it
was a choice it was a choice i made
because i got to imagine your father's
never been to therapy never would do him
a world of good hilario like these guys
that like how old your dad now my dad's
66 is your mom how old same similar age
are they still together they again one
of those they're roommates okay they do
live under the sun well now they have
yeah they they separate rooms at this
point i think now that everyone's moved
out and there are rooms like it was
literally like we grew up in a
let's see how many bedrooms there was
four bedrooms and there was
uh
two
four six people so it's like my parents
had a bedroom i was lucky enough to as
the oldest i had my own i think i was me
and my grandma were the only two people
that had our own rooms in that house and
then my brothers had to share you know
like they were twins so they fraternal
so they they split that's me and my
brother yeah you're about to make me cry
yeah yeah so it was like it was [ __ ]
ellis island style in that house you
know what i mean just like it's sharing
a wall with my grandmother just beating
off quietly
no lock on the door my foot's on the
bedroom door i'm just like
barely touching my penis i don't want
her to [ __ ] not you know
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah
no dude it was [ __ ] crazy it was just
like we were so packed in there
and so
i want to say i want to say this because
you'll appreciate this too i was just
back when i did the show at uh jimmy's
yeah um
and i my um i take my daughter and eva
with me right and i'm like i'm gonna
take you over to my she's my cousin but
she's really like feels like an aunt
because she's sure 70s yeah you know
what i mean like my dad's first cousin
yeah yeah yeah and i take see greek
people just we call that person an aunt
i always found it weird aunt patty i
always found it weird where people i
think technically that would make her
your second cousin
yeah her
which makes no [ __ ] she's an aunt
yeah she's she's like she's not a cousin
but anyway and she's little and so i put
i have a picture of my daughter my
daughter's seven she's almost got her by
like this yeah yeah yeah yeah so um
i go get ready to time travel and they
go what do you mean i go she hasn't
changed this house since she moved in in
1967. that's awesome and we go in and
she lives on holly bird avenue somebody
pinned that one halibut
dog right there on a row home to damn
you could see this side of the street
over here it did some [ __ ] these people
did not do this yeah yeah yeah of course
their handrails are rusty going up yeah
yeah and when you walk in it's that same
little house you know you the little
tiny square living room right here yep
little tiny dining room here kitchen
here immediately up the stairs here
tight turn yeah bedroom bedroom
still with the black and white checkered
floor oh my god and the stove doesn't
work it's the same
general electric stove like her fridge
says frigidaire yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i was like
the fridge outside is yellow
and it's like how
yeah no those those homes are [ __ ]
yeah that's and that's how greek that
was too it's like these little we were
talking about it a little bit before the
show but it's like these little houses
their architecture is dog [ __ ] they're
these little boxes that only they were
there's a little square brick uh yeah
brick with homes cut into them literally
they only exist because they were off a
trolley line and they needed somewhere
to house iron workers so it's like this
old [ __ ] that does it's like a vestige
of a [ __ ] a city that doesn't [ __ ]
exist anymore like uh but you know which
the houses are dog [ __ ] but i still part
of me just loves the neighborhood man i
can't i love it i can't get away as soon
as i see it on tv i'm like that's
baltimore yeah right away yeah yeah yeah
no it's sick
um but yeah i mean it was just the guilt
of the you know the fam immigrant [ __ ]
of like
and and i think growing up it's like
your dad my dad would pin the like
basically the hopes of like he kind of
saw us as lottery tickets to get him out
of
his [ __ ] situation and uh he never
wanted you necessarily to go into work
with him or anything like that no he in
fact he would threaten that as like
you better [ __ ] study or you'll end
up like me type of [ __ ] oh real like
that kind of thing yeah yeah he had a
whole he had a real like you know martyr
complex these [ __ ] you know these
immigrant dads that think they're their
lives are the hardest in the world
they've never done a chore in their
[ __ ] life you know what i mean
they're just out there [ __ ] uh always
like but that's the thing when you're
when you go from your mother babying you
to like your wife doing it it's like
yeah he's like it's not like his life
was easy but it's like it's
it's not that hard either he's never
washed underwear yeah exactly
i would rather be it's like
let's put it this way my mom never like
went and [ __ ] sat in a coffee house
and played cards with her friends for
three days in a row right when she
should have been working you know what i
mean like
um so yeah so that was the guilt of it
but i was just i felt so horrible
because i was like i was good at school
but i hated it you know and i always
just knew how to game the system like i
was good at getting great good grades
but it's not like i even studied that
hard i just kind of
you know
like when i got to when i got to that
middle school that i was telling you
about where it's like the best i went
for being like the smartest kid in like
my shitty little school
to like every kid was smarter than me
like in that middle school like i was in
the best
so i was like that i went from being
like and that's when kind of
i started honing the funny identity of
like well i'm not the smartest kid
anymore i'm not some [ __ ] nerd goody
two-shoes that i thought i was you know
when i was as you know so now it's like
let me cheat off these kids and let me
let me make them laugh so they'll give
me their homework and like
this is a much easier life you know
um and so i was finally like i was just
like
i kept trying to force that like let me
just get good grades let me do the
traditional
route of success but
i couldn't [ __ ] do it and eventually
i just like my senior year of college i
was just kind of checked out
so you said you went to umbc right yeah
so you actually went all the way did you
graduate well
hilariously like guilt took you at least
through three years of college well
here's the funny thing i walked my
graduation right i i ended up with like
a three nine gpa right for high school
for college or for college and
but i damn dude but i yeah it was i was
i just knew kind of how to like [ __ ]
you know whatever it was school was just
like you just had to time it the right
way you had to game the system but i
i never got i still need six language
credits
because they but they let you they let
you if you have under uh if that you
have the amount of credits you could do
in a summer they let you walk and the
the you know
the implication is you'll get them only
a [ __ ] lunatic would go through
college and walk do everything and not
get
his degree
and i was just like i don't [ __ ] want
to do this and i knew greek by the way i
could have tested it out i was about to
say it was like
i was about to say you had to go to new
york and set up a whole [ __ ] you can't
do that [ __ ] online right now for you
probably could you easily could but i
just find i think it's funnier to never
actually grab to almost graduate and
never do it it'd be better to register
for it set it all up and then never do
it
now that i live in new york too that's
the only way are you showing up
so yeah i technically yeah i technically
never graduated and i lied for a year i
was a paralegal for years i just lied
about having a degree no one [ __ ] you
were a paralegal i was apparently go to
a very shitty law firm yeah yeah what's
some of the
wild [ __ ] you saw come through there
dude so this was so my friend worked
there right and i didn't really have any
idea what the
law firm was really like but i was in
the midst of saving up money to move to
new york and i was actually working at
the ccbc
catonsville
county testing center and it was a fun
job it was really easy you just had to
like sit there and make sure like
nurses that were taking you know
continuing education courses didn't
cheat on their online tests basically
that's what it was there for but you
didn't make that much money and my
friend was a paralegal and he was like
yeah he pays this much i remember what
it was but at the time it was like you
know more money than i'd ever made and i
was like [ __ ] it i can do that um
but it was like it was basically a
foreclosure mill where it was like and
none of the it was they weren't doing
any maryland law it was this weird scam
where they got lawyers who were barred
in florida which apparently is like the
easiest like just the [ __ ] dumbest
lawyers who can't get barred anywhere
else sounds right get barred in florida
and so all these guys all these guys
lived in maryland but were borrowed in
florida and we're just doing foreclosure
law firm law and it was like and it was
during the
during the aftermath of the housing
crisis and i was like i don't want to be
a part of this this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
like i'm not i was like i'm not gonna
[ __ ] just like help banks
take homes from people that were like
tricked into getting these loans so i
was like i'm just gonna work for like
i was like i i worked for i was getting
trained and when it all when i figured
out this was the only law these people
did and the whole thing was a scam to
employ the dumbest lawyers that i mean
there were some cool guys there but most
of them were [ __ ] you know mongoloids
over there you know what i mean they
were just like like and that was
important for me because i went there i
was like oh
lawyers are [ __ ] idiots too like i
was like because you know you grow up
and you're it's like a esteemed position
lawyers doctors are always just like
yeah just like everything else
half of those people are [ __ ] morons
that's what they say you know what they
call the guy who finished last in
medical school
doctor yeah yeah yeah exactly
the dumbest doctor is a doctor yeah yeah
there's you know there's plenty of
smarter people in them so i just kind of
checked out i was like i'm not gonna do
[ __ ] and this place was so like weirdly
run and like poorly managed that they
didn't really like notice for like seven
months so i was just that you were
i got i got hired in like
i got hired like august
and and i did work for like
you know a month until i kind of figured
out the lay of the land and then i was
like i don't want to be a part of this
and i just was like all right well i
might get a paycheck or two out of it by
the time they put it together but then
it went through like the holidays and
once you get to thanksgiving no one
[ __ ] no one's gonna do anything from
thanksgiving to december right then i
got to [ __ ] it then it's like all right
i'm looking around i'm like all right
it's january the [ __ ] they didn't fire
me until march of that year so i was
just in there
my boss would walk by i would like
touch my computer to like make it look
like it was but it wasn't even logged in
like the screen saver the screen saver
would pop off and it would be like log
you know start your day or whatever and
i just would take two hour lunches i
would just i wasn't doing [ __ ] and that
was the best job i've ever had because i
was like i was like hey i'm [ __ ] i'm
robin hood over here i'm stealing time
from this law firm
i'm i'm obstructing i'm obstructing
these uh you know [ __ ] up housing
seizures and um and i was just writing
all day i was just i was getting that
was one of the times i got the best of
comedy because i would wake up
i'd have to be in physically being at
work so i'd start my day at like 8 a.m
get up i was writing all day like i was
writing comedy i was like i was like on
facebook like networking
messaging people back when facebook was
the social media everyone used i was
like [ __ ]
just
it was great twitter i was back in the
day this is how [ __ ] long ago it was
i was tweeting from my
you i would text my tweets to a number i
don't think i had a smile i didn't get a
smartphone until late and it was just
like it was great man it was like a
[ __ ] an incredible time in my life
where i was just like stealing money
from this horrible law firm and by which
by the way uh the owner of just they
sued them for unlawful practices and the
guy killed himself holy [ __ ] he just
shot himself in the office
yeah yeah yeah my friend got fired i
didn't get my security deposit back
so yeah dude my friend got fired because
a a female boss sexually harassed him he
was and he called it out and they just
fired him
there was a there was a law there was a
there was a lawyer who would just who
would like the hot secretaries you'd be
like hey i'll [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] uh
put your case to the top of the line if
you show me your [ __ ] it's just like
this is just the most dirt bag in
rosedale actually in the place of your
family's dreams
philadelphia literally on philadelphia
road not even kidding with you
uh it was a shitty and it was just the
most unlawful shitty [ __ ] law firm
people were [ __ ] like it was just they
employed the most tragic
and there's these [ __ ] disgusting
white trash girls are like okay
people were [ __ ] in the parking lots
and [ __ ] it was just like
[ __ ] trashy dude it was awesome but
they didn't
they weren't on to me for [ __ ] months
they were too busy doing everything else
yeah yeah i made so much i made so much
money just doing nothing over there it
was great and then i moved and i had
enough money uh i moved to new york the
next year i saved up a bunch and then
moved have your parents been to see you
perform live
um yeah yeah yeah my mom they have my
mom
has more recently
um
but i'm interested they think of what
you do
you know or how you do it let's say that
sure well you know they're not they
don't really check in that much you know
they don't listen
they're not they're not subscribers god
no no no no one should but especially
not my [ __ ] parents
um
but uh oh that's the story i was telling
where she's bragging her friend and
she's talking about yeah he's doing very
good you know like all these like and
then and then he's got the show with his
friends and a lot of people listen and
then i just hear a pause and she's like
um it's uh it's called the gum town
and just all the wind ever sails just
[ __ ] drops
she can describe it when it comes to the
actual thing she was [ __ ] devastated
but
but my mom is just so insanely
supportive and actually when i was at
that at that paralegal job she didn't
know i wasn't doing [ __ ] she thought i
cause i i had moved i was i moved back
home when i got that job because i was
like if i'm gonna work a full-time job
and do comedy i'm just gonna eat sleep
work comedy there's no reason to have my
own place there's no reason to spend
money i'm just saving up to move to new
york so i was like [ __ ] it i'll move
back home like i'll i'll do that you
know i'll swallow my pride and just do
that
and my mom saw me wake up i would wake
up every morning early i would go to
work she didn't know i wasn't doing [ __ ]
there but i would come home eat dinner
drive right to dc every night for a year
and a half you know so she was like oh
because she thought
she my mom thought i was smart because
you knew i was a little lazy so she
thought oh he wants to do comedy just
gonna go out get drunk be a bar like she
thought it was that [ __ ] but then she
saw how i was actually
working basically two jobs and commuting
basically every night to dc for better
stage time and i think for her it
clicked she was like oh he's not [ __ ]
this happens to be the thing he actually
wants to do he's would i prefer if he
was a [ __ ] lawyer or you know
whatever just something sure but
she she was happy that like i was
really working hard and ever since then
she's been super supportive and it's
it's easy too because i made enough
money where i can be like all right let
me [ __ ] right help you out here it's
like that that's nice that's really the
turning point
what does that feel like to be able to
help your parents insane i mean the
house i bought in baltimore was because
my family like yeah on some level it's
an investment and it was really cheap
like let's be honest i'm not you know
i'm not [ __ ] a millionaire over here
but a baltimore house costs what what a
quarter of a down payment costs in la or
new york so it was affordable but i
bought it because my my family was still
living like that and it's like the way
we grew up it's like my little brother
was still living with them my grandma
was still there they were all kind of at
each other's throats
and where'd you buy the place and
literally a block a block behind and two
blocks over
like from where we grew up so now my bro
at first my brothers were both living
there then one of them moved out he got
a job uh in like you know uh you bought
a home for your family yeah exactly
because i was like you guys need to gen
three generations your grand mom your
parents and your brothers and so my
brothers moved it's [ __ ] fantastic no
that my parents stayed in that probably
cost you 125.
nothing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
my brothers lived there and i was like
you guys need to get away from our
parents so i bought that and so
and then i redid my mom's my mom and my
grandma
that house the original ones they still
live there and my brothers moved to the
other one then one of my brothers moved
in with his girl in like columbia
somewhere out there he got a good job
over there he's a personal trainer um
and uh and fitness coach strength coach
and uh
um so yeah that was cool and then i
redid my mom's uh
her little her my grandma stayed in like
they turned my brother's room into like
their little
girl cave you know what i mean they have
like like recliners they watch greek
cooking shows all the time so for
christmas this year i remodeled that
[ __ ] i paid off my mom's dead if that
felt awesome you know what i mean
uh and it's also hilarious because
you're like
you realize again this is how not to get
too [ __ ]
i'm really not a polit i'm trying not to
be a political guy but it's like you
just see the realities of people's lives
and it's like the amount of money my
mother
like kept her up at night
was really not that much but it's like
poor people just cannot get under like
five thousand dollars that could like
ruin a person's life they could cut and
it's like in the grand scheme of things
like that's you know you could save up
you could do a couple shows whatever
like it's possible to make that money
but it's like when your whole life is
just survival and you just have to get
your kids out you have to worry about
your elderly mom it's like that i was
like jesus christ how many people have
it like worse than my mom yeah who just
don't have who's you know son didn't get
lucky with a [ __ ] podcast you know
what i mean yeah
yeah so
it was really [ __ ] it was really
[ __ ] up to realize like god damn it's
like most people
thousand bucks you just like keep them
from upward mobility and it's just it's
insane but
it felt incredible that felt awesome for
sure and uh you know that's a dream come
true story that's the dream and thank
god my family's from baltimore so it's
the overhead is low and achieved
when you grow up poor your dreams are
pretty achievable
[Laughter]
i want to get to uh because we got to
wrap up here sure i want to hear this uh
story about yeah yeah yeah how you tour
your yeah what was it your planner fast
my planner fashion yeah it's funny i i
respect i have to it's so funny to come
to l.a and do podcasts and you guys try
so much harder than everyone in new york
everyone in new york is just like
[ __ ] we record our [ __ ] this is the
studio you guys have like prompts you
thought about it everyone's just like
yeah everyone's just like
we press record we're like all right an
hour
let's [ __ ] do it and then let's leave
like that's how the
the
the podcasting culture is so the
differences are stark but
uh no i was thinking about it because
it's like you know uh
i don't i haven't i can't compete with
some of the tragedies that people have
turned around like funny here you know
what i mean but i did have a horrible
time
la a couple years ago
um i was at i suffered a foot injury i
tore my plantar fascia in the most
embarrassing way it was at the skanks
fest basketball tournament what did you
do it was
nothing
dude it was like yeah it was like it
wasn't his level of like how hilarious
the like how severe and hilarious the
fall was but it was like i was just
playing about i was playing basketball
against like [ __ ] it it was literally
steve reynozi and ari shafir
not exactly athletic titans
i was like i couldn't i couldn't keep
those keeping up with those guys i was
like [ __ ] i just i was just playing a
game of basketball and i just hear a
[ __ ]
on my foot that's it i heard it pop and
i was like oh that feels weird but i was
still kind of like the adrenaline you
feel it bottom of my foot like center
kind of center but i still had that
adrenaline and it just kind of felt like
maybe i like
you know i used to i played a lot of
sports growing up so i was like oh maybe
i pulled some weird muscle on the bottom
of my foot kind of like when you pull a
hamstring it's like when it first
happens you can still kind of like go
because it's still warm and then i just
figured like ah i'll be [ __ ] up like i
might have to go home and ice it i was
still thinking like i'm gonna go home i
sit i'll be back for the shows
that night right i was gonna meet up
with this girl i was stoked you know
what i mean so i was like oh i have a
great night ahead of me i get i get home
and once the like adrenal wears off
excruciating pain i'm like whoa this is
[ __ ] weird i ice my [ __ ] up i don't
have insurance at the time so i'm just
like i'm not gonna go to the [ __ ]
hospital so i just make a i'm just like
all right i'll make an appointment with
a podiatrist this guy's like yeah you
[ __ ] and i have to go to some weird
no insurance i have to go to some like
just a guy who had an mri machine in his
basement you know what i mean
he's like you might want to hit this guy
up he does mris for 250 i'm like say no
more brother
it was like some [ __ ] weird medical
office and i'm like oh cool and then you
just go to a basement it's like just a
guy and i'm like oh this is not
affiliated with these doctors is it and
it was just like anyway i go get a
[ __ ]
bottom of the barrel mri
uh they're like yeah this [ __ ] is
complete you just it's so the the
plantar fascia is like the bottom of
your foot it's kind of like it connects
the back in the front it's kind of like
a band that connects them and i just
snap that [ __ ] um
and there's really no does it make your
foot like just drop or anything or is it
just painful it was just really [ __ ]
painful and i just can't put any weight
on i couldn't put any weight on it and
uh
you know i live on the on the on the
third floor of a walk-up there's no you
know there's no like is there no easy
way to get up and down and the guy was
just like your best bet might be just
like
you know four to six weeks
of complete rest just stay up on it
don't do [ __ ] and come out of it like
and then you will put a walking boot on
all this [ __ ] but like
i mean you know how crazy we all went
during the pandemic imagine if you have
a pandemic and the whole world just
keeps going so it's like there's none of
the freeing of like well i'm not
accomplishing anything but everyone else
neither is anyone else this was like
i [ __ ] i have to be in my house and
[ __ ] is just starting to go right for me
right i've i've started headlining you
know what i mean
i had a big tour coming up um and i was
booking it i was like [ __ ] am i gonna
even be able to go on this tour and dude
i just fully lost my mind i was so
bored i was so sad i was so depressed i
had this relationship that was on again
off again and i was like one day i was
like let's [ __ ] let's do it let's
make this will really [ __ ] and then
the next day i had like a panic attack i
was like uh we can't talk i'm sorry
don't speak to me you know what i mean
i'm just like i'm
ruining relationships i'm [ __ ] i'm
taking so much i'm getting so bored i'm
taking like
i did a quarter of mushrooms
in my home on my couch
just
losing my mind
just fully like
i'm trying to watch thor ragnarok i'm
like oh i just i watched ragnarok one
night on edibles the first night i was
like this movie rocks and i was like let
me watch it on [ __ ] ass or
first i watched the mushrooms then i
watched it on acid i'm just laying there
i'm i'm experiencing is it three
different movies dude it
that was it an insane experience like it
wasn't good like it was but it wasn't a
bad trip it was just like it was just
like i was on a roller coaster that i
was not ready for where i was just like
i'm imagining myself as a
two-dimensional like cartoon like like
no but it's all everything's in black
and white i was like what i'm like
feeling like i'm you know just on some
weird
just like um i don't even know how to
experience i explained it i was just
like
i'm i'm hanging on for dear life and
it's like i'm aware that i'm in my
living room and there's a movie but it's
like that is not that is not what's
important to me at the time and i was
just like i got fat as [ __ ] yeah i just
don't do good without like
and it was just horrible dude it was
just like i can't i just i just like i
went and then so i'm cooped up for six
weeks i'm [ __ ] losing my mind i've
alienated like a girl that i would go on
we were going we would like patch things
up and go on the date but i did a lot of
[ __ ] damage in that time that just
net our relationship never
recovered from i don't think
and uh and then i'm like i go right into
a tour and it's just like i got a
walking boot on i'm i'm like i'm out
baby i'm getting [ __ ] up every single
[ __ ] night i'm eating like
completely i get so [ __ ] i get fat as
hell i'm just like the i'm i'm my penis
will not i have to take so many dick
pills that like my head is a balloon you
know what i mean like the like you could
just like if you pressed on my eyeballs
like [ __ ]
like [ __ ] air would come out through
my nose and ears you know what i mean
like just to get my dick even
seventy percent
and i'm just with a walking boot on
getting sucked off by some girl in a
hotel
just like this rocks you know what i
mean drunk as [ __ ] off a bacon
cheeseburger
just i mean oh my god it was
such a [ __ ] horrible time
uh my friends are losing their at the
same time that i'm going through this uh
my friends the podcast is so weird
because the guys are coming to my
apartment and recording but i'm losing
my mind uh my nick my friend nick is
having like his own weird
like i asked like you know mental [ __ ]
going on so i'm worried about him he's
literally like losing it i'm like and i
don't even care i'm like great i don't
awesome i'm like life's over i don't
[ __ ] care i'm just right i'm like i'm
like i'm
good everything is uh everything is just
slipping away from me and it was just
like
i don't know man it was it was one of
the worst
just a horrific
6 to 12 weeks because then it's like i
get out of there
i go on this tour then the tour ends and
i'm like
just
i have to basically like go into like
fat rehab where i'm like
go to baltimore make you sure your
brother like works out with you like you
can't be around drugs you can't do any
of that stuff and that's i'm on and
unfortunately that's the cycle of my
life where it's like i that happened to
me the pandemic too where i was like at
the end i got really healthy i lost a
bunch of weight i went did all this i
got fat as hell doing basically the same
thing
and then lost a bunch of weight then i'm
feeling great go on this tour
went buck [ __ ] wild with tour and now
i'm like now i'm like still on the road
i'm like i need to go back i need to get
the fat rehab again i need to check in
that's not caroline it will
that's what i'm saying so
uh it's just it's a cycle of just like
forced isolation that makes me go crazy
i get a [ __ ] you know gain a bunch of
weight and then
i just [ __ ] i'm excited man once this
tour i'm pumped for the tour it's gonna
be great i hope everyone comes out to
see me the shows are really fun
it's
creatively really fulfilling to do
something new because the last tour
i was trying to fine-tune my hour so
it's a lot of like trying new joke
trying old jokes trying little tags
tinkering but it's mostly the same [ __ ]
this is like i'm trying to [ __ ]
create an hour out of [ __ ] nothing so
it's really like it's scary but it is
like
you're performing you're trying or
you're super aware every second trying
to like so the shows are fun but i
cannot wait to just be done with it and
just take like i might i'm gonna be
going for like three months just in a
cabin somewhere [ __ ] eating good like
you know working out all this kind of
[ __ ] that's my that's my dream is like i
would love a cabin where i could just go
you know [ __ ] off to and then also have
like a weird barn gym where i just get
just come back to new york weirdly
jacked
like just [ __ ] my hair just keep
growing my hair out come with like a
full
full ponytail just like [ __ ] it
what's up what's up guys
well dude thank you for coming on here
of course this is great it's been a long
time coming i know i'm so happy to be
able to do it uh yeah man um i asked
everybody i mentioned to you before at
the top uh before we recorded 16 year
old me what advice would you give
dude you're 16. i've i've been thinking
about this because i've just uh
i would just say
you're a cute kid
that's all i would say because i went
back i was looking like this is the most
i've ever [ __ ] in my life and i like i
know i've gotta
you know i i gotta think about me i'm a
i've got i'm a charming guy i'm
entertaining
uh
vis
physiologically no one's [ __ ] because
of the way i look right i've got a diner
owner aesthetic going on i own it i like
it i think it's funny to have you know
long balding hair i think it's funny to
you know be fattest [ __ ] with a little
mustache the other thing i love about
you is you don't take yourself seriously
you know what you had that tooth missing
from you
for two years yeah yeah i didn't have it
that's the other thing i i i i before i
uh broke my plantar fascia i had the
tooth had popped out and i had like a
weird uh
uh cancer scare in my jaw where i had it
where i had a growth that a doctor one
dentist like when he saw the x-ray like
turned white in the face it was like oh
you have to go to an oral surgeon right
now so i thought i was going to die for
a while
it was a it was a benign tumor thank god
but
uh yeah so that i was toothless i had a
[ __ ] biopsy my [ __ ] was all [ __ ] up
but yeah dude i was i was looking at
that i was looking at my
i one of my best friends got married and
she was my substitute prom
like my girlfriend at prom this girl i
was dating like just like i found out
was cheated on me like right before prom
so my best friend christina we grew up
together
she came in last minute as like all
right i need the kids at my school to
thank a hot girl like just come her dad
owned a car dealership we roll up in
like a bright orange uh smart car back
when those were like a super novelty you
know um and i was looking at our prom
pictures because she i actually just uh
officiated her wedding and i was looking
at prom picks i was like
oh this is a [ __ ] cute kid i was so
self-conscious full head of hair i was
in i thought i was fat dude
i was i would [ __ ] you know cut off
my left toe
to look to be as fat as i thought i was
in [ __ ] high school right and i was
that's all i would say because i was so
self-conscious about my body and now
it's probably gone the other way where i
i could probably use a little more
self-consciousness
i dude i was because i
i want to lose weight because i feel bad
right like i've physically have been
like i've been getting so [ __ ] up and
eating like [ __ ] that i was just like
wake up every morning and i just don't
feel good but like i look in the mirror
i'm like hell yeah dude i love what
you're doing over there
fat as [ __ ] but i think i look awesome i
i have a little too much body confidence
now maybe but that's all i would say to
my my 16 year old self because i think
i'm paying for a lot of those hang-ups
now right because it's like you you're
always like relationship stuff is hard
for me it's like you know
i i've been like you know
at a certain point you get to the point
where it's like at a certain age it's
not cool to [ __ ] all the time it's
pathological you know what i mean so
it's like i'm trying to get out of that
like mindset and like be more of just
like i think i'm paying for like the not
feeling desired as a younger kid or like
feeling like self-conscious about my
body and not making like those
connections
younger like that you know my first
girlfriend serious girlfriend wasn't
until like late in college and i didn't
like you know and even my first really
good relationship i didn't that i really
tried super hard on wasn't until
you know three years my last
relationship like three years ago so i
think a lot of that body stuff like kind
of kept me self-conscious kept me from
like
exploring the regular life parts of
stuff that then once you go into
stand-up like we were talking about
earlier that kind of gets put on the
back burner anyway
so now i'm like this [ __ ] 30 year old
guy who's like what do i even want out
of a relationship you know what i mean
so i'm going through all this like
psychological you know big picture
questions where it's like if i had just
gotten sucked off a couple more times
at 17 if i was just just down there over
on merit boulevard getting sucked off
if i just if i just let the because i
went to roland park it was like mostly
i was like you know it's like 10 white
it's mostly
all baltimore city public schools
it's like mostly black kids but there's
this one white trash girl who like did
her bangs like
you know that like curl though they
stayed there stay there [ __ ] whatever
it was so funny because it was almost
like we could have like paired off like
cartoons where it's like you know like
alvin and the chipmunks all their
girlfriends are like just girl versions
of them and our middle school was like
yeah some chubby
some chubby white trash girl with huge
tits it was like that should have
i i think i heard she had a crush on me
but i was like so
self-conscious that i was like well i
don't know what to do i just think about
what if i had just seen those big white
trash titties you know what i'm saying
like in in eighth or ninth grade they're
women now when i go back to baltimore to
tell me like they had this crush on me
i'm like why come on
yeah you tell me that i would be yeah i
would be just like when you were jerking
off next to grandma's room with the
[ __ ] foot on the door
but with the silencer over my dick
[Laughter]
i'm i'm spoofing i put a
spoof over my dick i'm just beating off
but yeah that's my advice
who knows if getting jacked off in ninth
grade what the trajectory of my life
would be maybe i'd be just a a happy
small business owner with three children
i would never do comedy i wouldn't feel
the need to prove anything how much who
knows but that's my advice believe in
yourself and that's the advice i give to
so many you know whenever you know
there's a lot of
a lot of little plus size boys are in my
dms being like
what do i do and i'm like bro just
you're you're good enough brother you
just got to believe in yourself right
now
but yeah um well thank you thank you for
being here
plug whatever you want again please yeah
yeah come see me on the road go to
stavi.biz slash tour s-t-a-v-y dot bid
slash tour
uh a lot of stuff coming up like i said
sf
um vancouver we'll see uh chicago st
louis all these dates i'm doing a run
through the south go to stobby.biz
instagram stavybaby2
and tiktoknowstoppybaby2
and twitter stubbybaby so that's all the
stuff yep well thank you and the special
when it comes out yes
thank you bro ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you